hi my name is jack calvin
i've been a professional juggler for
over 30 years i've traveled all around
the world performing my show
and i've taught thousands of people how
to juggle today i'm going to teach you
the most basic
three-ball juggling pattern it's called
the cascade
and then i'll show you some of my
favorite three ball tricks
[Music]
to learn the cascade we're going to
start with just one ball and the first
thing we need to do is learn to throw
and catch one ball properly
so start with your hands out in front of
you with your palms facing up we're
going to hold the ball loosely in one
hand
and then bring it down by your side
before throwing it and the goal is to
get it to go up
and come down and land right in the
other hand
so we're going to keep our hands down
here and keep your eyes up here at the
top
look at the ball when it reaches the top
actually try to focus on the ball
some jugglers will say look through the
pattern juggle peripherally
but when you're learning it's a lot
easier to focus on the ball
you get the most information about where
it's going to land that way i keep my
shoulders relaxed
and i throw mostly with my elbow i'll
turn to the side so you can see that
better
and i throw the ball about as high as my
head or slightly higher
you want to predict where the ball is
going to land and then put your hand
under it so don't reach up to catch the
ball
wait for the ball to come down if your
throws are good the catches will be easy
practice this for a few minutes keep
throwing the ball back and forth
try to get it always to go to the same
height
try to do it without reaching very far
you should be able to do this with your
eyes closed
well maybe not really with your eyes
closed but you can
feel like you can do it with your eyes
closed if this is too easy and boring
try some tricks
throw it under your leg see if you can
do it with your hands really wide
or you can try throwing it over your
shoulder or
behind your back but don't get too crazy
with it we want to have mostly successes
that's really all you need to do that's
the basic move you're going to need to
juggle three balls
so once you've got that mastered we can
move on to
two balls
[Music]
okay now we're ready for two balls hold
one ball in each hand
just like you did before you're going to
throw the first ball up
about that high and when you see it
start to come down you're going to throw
the second ball
under it it's going to look like this
throw throw
don't worry about catching them the
catches will come later
the important thing is make two good
throws
get them both up to the same height
right left
and if you throw them both to the same
height they'll come down catch catch
right left left right
look at each ball when it gets to the
top right
left left right
notice i keep it all in one plane here i
don't reach out in front of the other
ball to throw
right left left right after each two
throws stop
and relax then visualize what you want
to happen
you want to practice this until it's
easy if you can do it about 10 times in
a row
you're ready for three balls
okay we're finally ready for three balls
hold two balls in one hand one ball in
the other and you're going to want to
put the two balls in the hand that you
want to start with
i'm going to start with my right the
first two throws are going to be exactly
the same
but when you see the second ball come
down that's when you throw the third one
and it's going to look like this one
two three if you do it right
all the balls will cross to the opposite
hand they'll all go to the same height
you'll have a nice even rhythm one two
three one two three
a lot of people have a hard time
throwing the third ball so it helps to
say the numbers out loud
one two three i know it's not easy but
we want to try to keep everything in one
plane here we don't want anything to go
forwards or backwards
one two three just do three throws and
stop and every time you throw
notice that you're throwing under the
ball that's coming down
scooping the ball into the middle every
time one two three
did you catch them all congratulations
you are now juggling
three balls
okay here's an alternate exercise you
can try two balls in one hand
this may be less confusing there's only
two balls you only have to use one hand
at a time
but you do have to move that one hand
faster than if you're just juggling
three balls
again try to keep everything in one
plane
like this you're always scooping into
the middle
and throwing it from near the middle of
your body but now instead of crossing
over the other side
as you did with three balls you're
throwing it back to the same hand so
you're gonna throw it that way
when you're doing two in one hand you're
always throwing from the inside to the
outside
and notice that if you do this with both
hands
at the same time you'll be juggling four
balls
it's the easiest way to do four balls
this is called the fountain
and it might look like the balls are
crossing if you get your hands close
together
but you can see by the different colors
that they never switch hands
you can also do them synchronized like
this
but we're getting ahead of ourselves
back to three balls
[Music]
one two three when three throws feels
comfortable
just don't stop when the third ball
comes down you'll throw the fourth ball
up one two three four
one two three four and again it'll help
to count
because some people get stuck after the
third one one
two three four right
left right left
just try to get all the balls to the
same height nice even rhythm
focus on each ball at the top remember
to stay relaxed especially your
shoulders
the most common problem that people have
is throwing out in front of them when
they juggle
we want the balls to stay right in front
of our face when we juggle
so to fix the problem of throwing
forwards i suggest
trying to overcompensate lean back a
little bit and try to walk backwards
when you juggle
i find that that suggestion helps a lot
of people
the best way to improve your juggling is
just to keep practicing the more you do
it the easier it gets
and eventually you don't even have to
look at the balls anymore
you can look through the pattern and
juggle with your peripheral vision
you can read a book you can watch
television the more time you put in the
better your juggling will be
okay so now you're comfortable with the
cascade and we can start to get creative
with it
fortunately there are literally an
endless variety
of tricks you can learn with three balls
i've been doing this for over 30 years
and trust me
you never run out of options for new
tricks to explore
i'm going to show you some of my
favorites right now a common first trick
to learn
is throwing one over the top instead of
scooping in
to throw you're going to scoop outward
and throw it up over the top
be sure to try it on the other side too
and if you keep one ball going back and
forth over the top
it's called tennis
you can stretch it out you can learn it
with
all the balls on one side that's called
a half reverse
be sure to learn the other side
and if you do it with both sides it's
called a full reverse or a reverse
cascade another fairly easy trick to try
is the one up two up
or columns
start by just throwing one ball high in
the middle and then wait for it to come
down
and then go back into a cascade
when that starts to feel comfortable you
can throw one ball up high in the middle
throw the other two on the outside and
then throw the one back up in the middle
again
and then go back into a cascade so it'll
be one
two one back to a cascade
one two one back to a cascade
and then you can just keep going this is
a lot easier if you've worked on two in
one hand because basically that's what
you're doing
your right hand is doing two in one hand
but instead of doing it in a circle
as you were doing before you're doing it
in columns
my right hand is just doing two in one
hand my left hand is mirroring one of
the throws
another similar trick is right right
left left in this trick
the hands take turns doing two in one
hand for just two throws
right right left left right right
left left both hands get practice at
doing two in one hand
and learning two in one hand is the
basis for a lot of great tricks
with practice you can get good enough
with two in one hand you can move the
other hand independently
this enables you to then follow one of
the balls
and create a lot of interesting patterns
if you learn these tricks with both
hands it opens up a world of
possibilities
here's a fancy three ball start that's
easier than it looks you hold three in
one hand like this
and the key to this is that it's all in
the flick of the wrist
like that we'll do it with just two
balls first practice just throwing
flicking your wrist so that one ball
goes a lot higher than the other
you can start like that so the high one
goes across to the other hand
when that feels good try it with all
three just have that one ball
that you're going to push higher than
the other two
we'll throw all three of them up grab
the two low ones
so that you're ready for the third one
and then you can try it under your leg
[Applause]
which is not any harder okay one more
thing you need a fancy finish here's my
favorite
it's called a one up 360. let's just
practice the spin part
we're going to throw one high throw it
very high so you have time then we're
going to spin around and catch it and
don't try to look at it the whole time
it's up there
throw then spin then look for it to
catch
if the throw is good it'll be easy then
put it into the juggling
tada thank you for watching i hope
you'll enjoy juggling as much as i do
if you have any questions leave them in
the comments keep on practicing and
don't forget to subscribe to wired